whoa before we get started I want to go
over the four sponsors for this episode
who make all this possible
they're fantastic so go show them some
love the first is the best URL in the
industry crypto comm their crypto
platform with one goal driving mass
adoption that's why we're all here right
to get every human on earth a digital
wallet and to get them using digital
currencies crypto comms helping people
do that through buying earning lending
and a new card payment everything you
could want is at crypto calm they've
been longtime supporters of
off-the-chain and recently announced a
new exchange so go help them out
download their app from the App Store or
visit crypto comm and tell them pom sent
you there's nothing better in the world
than a company helping to drive global
adoption of this new technology another
part of global adoption is making sure
that we secure the various block chains
with computing power coin mine has built
the best consumer experience in mining
hands-down no competition if you want to
help secure the blockchain and get
started in mining you can go to coin
mine comm slash pop order a coin mine
it'll arrive at your door
and you simply take it out of the box
plug it in and connect to your Wi-Fi
you'll be mining your favorite crypto in
five minutes or less it is honestly
magical I have one running right now
here in the office and it's super quiet
it's got no heat and every person that
comes in the office asks what is that
every single person asks it's a coin
mine the best part to me is that the
coin mine comes with a mobile app that's
super slick and the company continues to
push over-the-air updates to the device
that add functionality ad tokens that
can be mine or increase the efficiency
of the device similar to how Tesla does
car software updates over the air
coin mines sending these passively to
thousands of coin mines around the world
on a periodic basis pretty damn cool
when far booed and the team pitched me
on the idea of an Xbox or Playstation
like box that could mine cryptocurrency
in your home I was immediately sold I
invested in the business have a device
personally and keep telling people to go
to coin mine comm / pump so they can
save a lot of time if they want to get
started mining today in coin mine has a
partnership with our third sponsor for
this episode block 5 block 5 is one of
my favorite companies in crypto because
they allow users to deposit their assets
in a deposit account and immediately
start earning interest think about it if
you keep your digital assets on an
exchange or in cold storage you aren't
benefiting from any yield on the
asset with block fie they allow you to
deposit crypto and then get paid
interest on a monthly basis in crypto
deposit Bitcoin and want to get your
interest payment in eath you can do it
deposit Bitcoin and want to get your
interest payment in Bitcoin you can do
it the rates have block fire are
currently some of the best in the
industry
you can earn six percent interest on
Bitcoin and you can earn up to eight
point six percent 8py on G USD deposits
I'm an investor in the company and think
block fights building really important
and compelling infrastructure so go
check them out at block fire comm slash
pump again this block five comm slash
pump and that brings us to the last
advertiser of the episode eToro these
guys have absolutely crushed it over the
years their founder yoni was one of the
original Bitcoin OGIS that has been
ahead of almost every trend in crypto he
built eToro to help people buy sell and
trade crypto currencies but he added a
few twists social trading copy trading
and virtual trading accounts social
trading is a feature where every asset
available on the platform has its own
separate social feed where people talk
about the asset share trading ideas and
analysis and even include various charts
or graphs virtual trading accounts is
targeted at beginners if you're just
starting out and want to try trading
with play money eToro will give you a
virtual account with $100,000 in it to
test learn and get comfortable and so
then that brings us to copy trading
which is by far the coolest feature this
allows you as a user to select any other
users portfolio to copy if you see
someone on the platform you like you can
set your account to mimic their trades
they buy Bitcoin with 5% of their
portfolio your portfolio buys 5% Bitcoin
they sell 50% of their ether position
your portfolio does the same thing
automatically copy trading is awesome so
go join the 10 plus million other
traders on eToro and start trading all
the most popular cryptocurrencies today
they're one of the largest companies in
the space and you can get started by
going to e Toro comm again that is eToro
comm where the entire team is ready to
get you started in just a few clicks and
don't forget go subscribe to the
off-the-chain daily newsletter you can
go to off-the-chain sub stack comm I
write a letter of news analysis and
opinion every morning that goes out to
more than 40000 investors see you there
what's up everyone this is anthony pop
Leon Oh most of you know me as pomp
you're listening to off-the-chain simply
the best podcasting crypto let's kick
this thing off Chris Moors alack is the
co-founder and CEO of crypto comm in
this conversation we discussed the
obstacles to mass adoption in crypto how
companies are currently expanding
product lines and anticipation of the
next bull market why crypto comm
recently launched a new exchange and
what it has been like living in Hong
Kong recently giving Chris's fifteen
plus year history in the city I really
enjoyed this conversation and I hope you
do as well Anthony promptly on O is a
partner at Morgan Creek digital all
opinions expressed by pump or his guests
on this podcast are solely their
opinions and do not reflect the opinions
of Morgan Creek digital or Morgan Creek
Capital Management you should not treat
any opinion expressed by pomp as a
specific inducement to make a particular
investment or follow a particular
strategy but only as an expression of
his opinion this podcast is for
informational purposes only
alright guys bang bang I've got Chris
here who was calling in from Hong Kong
so thanks for taking the time to do this
thanks all right for sure and so you
obviously had a life before Bitcoin than
encrypt oh maybe let's start with kind
of growing up in Poland what that
experience was like oh that was quite
fun I don't want to bore you too much
with you know my childhood days but
there was a different country in the
eighties still you know before we switch
to democracy it was an interesting
upbringing and certainly lets you
appreciate all that you can enjoy right
now in the free world but I'm just a
company building I've been building
companies my entire life this is
Cryptococcus my fourth startup got it
and as you started thinking more about
Bitcoin and crypto what was the first
moment that you saw digital currencies
and kind of got excited like what kind
of grabbed your attention the first time
I looked at a bit calling was at the
over Christmas
2013 so I just sold my e-commerce
startup at that time from 20 million I
was thinking I would what should I do
next and the BTC price was going crazy
at a time so I looked into it but anyway
we all got GOx basically right soon
after so I kind of forgot about crypto
and the thing that brought it back for
me was the Dow hack into mid 2016 so I
wrote an article in the wire about it
and I was like 150 million dollars on
something like this I mean isn't this
thing supposed to be dead I mean that's
what I was left off right right after
the dogs it seemed that crypto would
never be able to recover after that and
here we are so I looked at it and at
that time I was just at the very early
days of our business and we looked at
entrance into getting distribution as a
fin tech startup through a debit card
with like perfect interbank exchange
rates kind of like you know reinvented
banking and we combine it with crypto to
to book charge the the chartered bank
offering and now it's you know over
three years and the thing came together
quite nicely
yeah and so let's talk a little bit
about kind of the the challenge of bank
situation right because I think what
most people have seen least in the
Western world for sure is we've got the
legacy banking system that are not very
technology enabled is probably a nice
way to put it
but in every other aspect of our lives
we've seen industries that have been
updated by the technologies with us user
experience as functionality etc and now
we're seeing this kind of like a salt on
the banking industry by technologists
and so that's coming from the crypto
world but it's also coming from more
kind of FinTech right so things that
don't necessarily involve crypto
blockchain how do you see just on that
kind of macro structural level give
those ciao
jurors competing with the legacy banks
who may have other advantages whether
the regulatory or the capital resources
etc you know I think banks are wonderful
competitors I mean they're just so bad
at it universally hated I need to find a
person I will say I just love my bank
you know it just doesn't happen in the
real world right so you're right that
they have the Vantage's they have the
balance sheets they have you know all
the licensing and all this stuff right
but startups are very good at starting
of something simple and then getting
distribution and then building all the
things that the banks have today but
we're building it now in a way this
better right
so oh and when we started we thought
okay we're just gonna offer you a fair
deal transparent fees were basically no
fees on your FX no annual fees basically
not screwing your customers it seems
like it's a very basic thing but banks
just operate differently and other 200
banks that came mostly out of Europe
like revolute and Monza were starting
they were all like you know serious a
stage now they are at multi-billion
dollar unicorns but they follow the same
principles you have the customer fair
deal
make sure that you've got great who acts
low fees I mean this is the the ultimate
combination the financial incentive to
join and getting your product and the
user experience just doesn't suck and
that's enough and over time as you get
distribution size you know you're
building all the infrastructure that the
banks have today the difference is that
you know some of the banks are running
on you know as400 mainframes even today
versus you know we built on a much more
advanced modern tech stack got it and
how much of those legacy banking issues
do you think our customer service
related so just you know that the kind
of
on technological elements suck versus
it's actually a technology problem and
if they had better technology they could
be solved I think it starts with the
culture so there is a lack of customer
centricity
there's no risk-taking
there's no innovating for customers and
everything just flows from that a large
banking institutions or just you know
full of people who are busy playing a
game of Thrones rather than focusing on
what to do for the customers right and
everything flows from that the kind of
decisions they make in terms of their
tax tag the kind of products they build
and now designed by committee and all
this stuff right everybody way you know
I understand that banks have regulators
on top of them and you know they need to
be compliant and all this stuff but even
if you look at this right they're not
doing a particularly good job I mean
banks have been fined to the tune of
tens of billions of dollars since 2009
right so even that thing is not done
well so I don't think it's just a
wonderful if you if you were to pick a
competitor I mean competing against
banks I think it's great
got it and how much of kind of that
culture it's a really interesting way to
look at it it's just like hey the
culture sucks and there are folks are
the wrong things and so everything kind
of top-down from there it is messed up
when you think through that culture you
know compare it to the crypto culture is
it things around like sovereignty
self-reliance etc or the other elements
to it that crypto breeze at the table
that you think kind of put the crypto
businesses or Krypton native companies
in a better position to serve customers
I think it's more about the culture of
the company than the whole crypto ethos
right so the basic stuff like you know
having a sense of ownership being
focused on the customer and I'm being
really humbled the the basics of being a
clear thinker
there's just missing
in the entire banking environment so I
would just just separate this completely
and and in terms of crypto we view this
as kind of building blocks that we can
use to come up with new value
propositions for customers and give them
more reasons to to try out crypto and
see you know if we can do a better job
than a traditional financial institution
but those two things are a little bit
different I think that before you start
talking about things like you know you
can get the control of your money back
or you know you know you can control
your data and identity which by the way
we think is a basic human right but
before you talk about this kind of high
level stuff for the mass-market user
things that matter are you know what
kind of value does this bring to me
today right what kind of problem does it
solve I mean things like you just look
at our offering right are our cards
three four five percent cash back
interbank rates now ATM withdrawal fees
in terms of the interest rate would we
offer much better than any bank would
offer right so this is the stuff that
people understand it just addresses the
direct need today and it makes their
life better today so after they actually
get to use it and we see the product and
you know they think it's great right
they become advocates and then they
start to you know be more open to
understanding you know how does a what
is a distributed level of technology and
then how does a Bitcoin change the world
but I think if we want to have mass
market adoption we have to start with
the customer value first and technology
needs to come second for sure instantly
as you kind of take that mentality let's
talk a little bit about crypto calm and
kind of where you guys originally
started what the vision for the business
was okay so we started as a company
wants to challenge the bank's right and
our vision today is crypto currency
never wallet so we think that it's in
terms of the impact it would be
hard-pressed to find anything else
you know in the technology field that
that you can work on that can change how
the society works arguably things are
not really going very well recently you
know you've got I don't know if you've
seen the great hack but you know you've
got you know people using big data sets
to influence elections to erode you know
your democratic rights not to mention
that you've got a massive data breaches
and all the stuff I think it's it's it's
time that people really get back to
control their money data and identity
and blockchain has the potential to
deliver on this promise of course you
know it's there's a long way from from
where we are today to and it's actually
going to happen but Bitcoin has shown us
that it is possible for sure it is to
walk us through kind of the products
that you guys offer today right so as
you think about building out a challenge
or through the bank's obviously there's
kind of a couple of components right one
is the the promise of better customer
service better kind of sovereignty for
individuals etc two is the products you
offer and then three is kind of the
regulatory environment that you operated
let's focus on the products right now
just kind of walk us through the product
suite that you guys have yeah so at the
center of it is today is a custodial
wallet it's arguably one of the most
powerful wallets for crypto you can find
out there we've got more than a million
users on it and you can do all the basic
stuff like you know by cryptography at
move from fear to crypto from crypt of
the Fiats there's like 50 coins on it
you can earn interest on your coins you
can get instant loans you know track
your portfolio all this functionality is
just beautifully designed product and
it's paired with with a metal Visa Card
where you can move from crypto to Fiat
and spend it so the card itself
got great perks you can get like three
four five percent cash back um all
transactions you can get access to
lounges for free and I'll free Spotify
net like something that matches the
lifestyle of the crypto user today but
most importantly it it gives people
peace of mind because you know you've
got access to your money at the citizen
crypto basically 24/7 365 which is very
powerful and to complete the the
ecosystem we're building our own public
chain which essentially works as a
replacement of payment networks like
Visa or MasterCard and we just announced
a crypto currency exchange where we'll
have full institutional offering
starting with sports then you know next
year margin trading lending and
derivatives so it's an entire ecosystem
like essentially whatever you need for
crypto just go to koat.com and you have
it all in one place and as you think
through that product offering do you
think each one of those products kind of
replaces a product offering from the
legacy world or do you think about kind
of crypto native products right things
that maybe you can't do in the legacy
world but through technology in this
world you can build that's a very good
question
look we've we're quite pragmatic so I I
don't believe that in today's world you
can you know roll out this type of
service these type of services to
millions of users globally without doing
things like you know compliance security
privacy all right so we're building
we're investing heavily in this
infrastructure that allows us to be
innovative but it's in time compliant
and we were like the first company in
crypto space Global Affairs ISO 27001
certification and you know put the
currency securities under level 3 PCI
DSS you know all this stuff that keeps
our platform compliant secure we are
investing in it you know just because
you have to and
and I you know realistically people who
are building even like the centralized
finance protocols and they didn't
technologically reach this level of the
centralization which would allow them to
just say okay and I don't need to get
this license with license just doesn't
work like this at least not today got in
you know one of the things that I keep
thinking about is crypto decent rise
finance etc stands to be fairly
disruptive to the legacy banking system
and the financial system but it feels
like those competitors right the people
that the challengers are trying to
disrupt they're not even paying
attention yet do you kind of get the
same sense or do you think that they're
actually paying more attention than we
realize and they're kind of working
quietly in the background I think that
we are as we as as the industry spends
today we are super super small niche and
there is over 50 million people in
crypto space globally today so you're
you're right that I love the plan you
know almost everybody kind of ignores
this which is great because that gives
us more time to build the technology and
the infrastructure that you need to
support a large scale business before
bigger players doing that's great a
thing for for us the other aspect of it
is that I think there's way too much
tribal is moving within crypto space I
mean everybody should realize how small
we are comparing to the broad finance I
mean from paymaster to finance through
all the way to the trading crypto super
super tiny today so we should all come
together and instead of competing for
this you know small little small size of
the cake we should work together in an
open collaborative manner to expand the
size of the market that's why we always
try to work on initiatives that grow
this industry and grow the adoption of
crypto
rather than trying to just compete
against players from living in the
industry got it and actually think about
that kind of collaboration that there's
obviously a lot of things that you guys
are doing but one of the pieces that I
want to spend some time talking through
is the card and kind of the user
experience that almost you know most
people in the world are used to of
pulling out a piece of plastic or metal
and swiping it has really allowed
traditional companies to add various
currencies behind that experience
various banking partners vendors etc you
guys are trying to you know really push
that with crypto behind it maybe talk a
little bit about how you're doing that
and then what the reasoning behind
making such a big push into the card
really is people understand how does
card work and you know having a Visa
brand on top of it brings instant
credibility and Trust and brings instant
utility of the product cause you now can
either than 50 million locations and the
perks are great so it's better than what
you're using today for your payments and
it it basically kills any bank card just
purely on the on how favorable the terms
are so I think it's a great tool to get
people in because in you know we are
early adopters we are very comfortable
trying out new stuff figuring things out
and ourselves right people sometimes
need something else is more familiar to
get into it and once they're in you know
they they can comfortably
absorb more information about this whole
crypto thing we are now live in in
asia-pac we are alive in 49 states in
the u.s. we'll start shipping to 30
countries in Europe in January so this
like the only crypto card is available
pretty much globally
and it's a really high quality product
so what we get out of it as a company is
basically a very strong word of mouth
it's a conversation starter it's just we
see it clear that people who have the
car in the world they just transact
heavily on the platform and use other
services just makes perfect sense got it
and in terms of you know kind of
competing on a product by product basis
one of the biggest things I've seen
crypto companies run into is obviously
the regulatory challenges and obstacles
you guys are based in Asia you
specifically live in Hong Kong maybe
talk a little bit about how you think
through the regulatory challenges that
crypto companies especially once they're
trying to provide true financial
services faced versus the kind of legacy
banking or all it may be the advantages
that they have there so we try to do it
in stages so the first thing you do is
you partner with people who already have
licenses so for example for a card
issuing we partner with metropolitan
commercial bank in New York called
principal member of visa and if they
have a banking license and they can just
issue cards all over the US we've got a
similar deal with twenty thirty billion
dollar thin tech player in Europe called
wild card so we just basically piggyback
off their existing licenses and
infrastructure to get the product to the
market first and start getting
distribution once you have distribution
and you know we're getting there because
we already have more than a million
customers on the platform you can start
getting your licenses and on one hand
you've got things like you know MTA or
licenses in the states or EMI licenses
in Europe but also you know it can
become a direct partner with companies
like visa for the principle membership
all right so as a start-up being to
think about what is achievable
and how do you get to the market with
the value prop for customers faster so
you can get distribution so that it can
be optimizing your cost structure and it
can be more control of your product and
destiny by getting all those vices by
yourself but it's very difficult to do
it from day one because it's a
multi-year process so now you know we've
got a team of over 200 people around the
world we've got customers on the
platform and we are getting this stuff
done by ourselves but you need to do it
in steps got it and so let's talk a
little bit more about kind of where we
end up right so you've got these
challenger banks that are going after
the legacy banking system there's this
regulatory framework that exists there's
some people who will argue that the
rules need to change there's some people
that argue the challengers need to play
by the rules that exists because they're
not going to change but but how do you
see kind of these two different forces
right the legacy world and the challenge
of bang's kind of colliding in the
future is it a thing where the legacy
banks end up having to acquire some of
these crypto startups and challengers or
do you see there being a kind of a
winner's crowned and one or the other
strategy ends up being victorious in the
end first of all I think that entire
industry is going to be regulated just
like traditional financial services so
if we fast forward three and three years
from today I mean crypto trading is
going to be fully regulated you know all
the services that are not backing what
looks similar to banking are going to be
fully regulated so we are already
working on this to be ready whether
there is going to be M&A activity it
really depends on what kind of scale we
can reach or other players in this
industry can reach so if you look at the
typical challenge of banks a clearly
successful example is revolute right
rebels got a user acquisition machine
and they are not losing that much money
capital is on tap for them mmm
they can go from you know whatever they
have six seven million customers now
they can go for twenty-five or thirty
million customers globally and they
don't need to sell they don't even have
to IPO and then if you look at things on
the crypto side you've got you've got
companies that have robust revenue
generating engines like liquid by next
week in two years and a billion dollars
in revenue right that's much more robust
and the typical challenger Bank so
there's absolutely no need for for
capital right they can just grow
organically so I think these type of
companies are going to be very expensive
acquisition target down the road as they
mature and as the regulatory frameworks
mature over time so obviously right now
and even in the last few years if you
saw I need to use in the crypto space or
a massive discounts being applied
because of the perceived regulatory risk
over time this is going to be fully
regulated so it's just this discount
will not be applicable so that's the way
I kind of look at it but for us at
Scripture of calm this is a purely
metaphysical conversation because we're
building something that is by definition
of for sale yep and as you think through
that like how do crypto corporations
right are companies in this kind of
global decentralized ethos based world
how do they think about alignment with
investors value creation value accrual
like do some of the core tenets of
building a company change or do you as
an entrepreneur think of a lot of the
same types of mechanisms and aspects of
company building it just happens to be
that the outcome changes where you're
not looking for kind of the acquisition
at yet yeah I think it's a little bit
counterintuitive
I would say that fundamentals stay the
same you still need to build a great
great team
you still need to deliver a product that
does the job for the
and I need to generate revenues and you
need to be profitable if you want to
have staying power
so I also you know I am I'm all for
building soldiers or censorship
resistance right but applying this type
of filter field like okay let's have a
decentralized team and you know the
centralized decision-making of the
centralized governance right this is not
how you build stuff at scale in the real
world so you know people should go back
to the basics I feel for sure and then
you're sitting in in Hong Kong you've
been living there for you know 15 plus
years maybe talk to us a little bit
about kind of situation and kind of what
you're seeing on the ground and given
the kind of historical context you have
over the last 15 years it's it's a tough
tough situation the societies it's
really split and it what's happening
here is really touching the very core
human being things like you know their
sense of justice right and when you go
there things just live there there will
never be reasonable right I've been here
for now 16 years Hong Kong is home for
me so obviously that's uh it's it's very
sad to watch this this happen it's
arguably one of the greatest cities on
earth but I'm sorry I'm I'm optimistic
when I watch the news but I remain
optimistic I think this too shall pass
and if I've learned anything in my 16
years in Hong Kong is that you just
don't that a bit guys Hong Kong people
mm-hmm they're very resilient Bunch
yeah do you feel like everyday life has
changed or is it somewhat
compartmentalized with the protests etc
but the kind of average person their
life hasn't actually seen that see no
material change it used to be that it
didn't have that much of an
in our day to day life but in the last
two weeks things have deteriorated quite
substantially right and you know it's at
the point where nobody can ignore it
hopefully things will get better soon
although one could argue that probably
do get worse before they get better so
I'll give you some practical insights
right like for example in the last six
months you know we've got like two days
where we told our team that you know
safety is your safety is our priority
they're gonna be instructions citywide
disruptions right so just work from home
last week was quite intense but you know
this the flip side of the coin is that
you know we've we've we've seen that the
investments in time and effort to build
a very strong company culture where
where people take ownership of what they
do and they take pride in what they do
regardless of university not being able
to sit in the office for a few days
I mean people didn't chop it in any
balls so it's pretty good skirt school
want to know who has the best URL crypto
comm that's right
crypto comm they're a crypto platform
with one goal mother mass adoption
that's why we're all here we're trying
to get crypto in every wallet curse.com
is helping people do that through buying
earning lending and card payment
everything you could want at crypto comm
go help your boy out tell them pump sent
you download the app or visit crypto
comm pumps got you always everyone to
get into mining and didn't know how
don't worry your boy pops gotcha
everybody got some electricity and Wi-Fi
all you got to do is go to coin mine
comm you buy a coin mine it's like an
Xbox or a Playstation that helps you
turn your electricity into Bitcoin
that's right
you purchase it it shows up at your
doorstep you pull it out of the box
you'll plug it in connect to your Wi-Fi
five minutes or less you're mining
Bitcoin all you have to do is control it
from the mobile app they provide
and then you receive over-the-air
updates that add new coins and new
features on a consistent basis kind of
like how Tesla does over-the-air updates
and updates the car software just your
update your coin mine
consumer mining made easy that's right
go to coin mine com
tell them pump Sencha and thank me later
one more word from our sponsor block by
their new interest account allows you to
securely deposit your Bitcoin or
Ethernet block by and receive 6% annual
interest paid monthly and cryptocurrency
this rate actually compounds so you
receive a 6.2 percent APY which is very
attractive given the alternatives so you
can actually take your Bitcoin you can
deposit it with block Phi and get paid
an interest rate of 6% in return go
check out block 5 comm / pump again
block 5 comm / pump to sign up and start
earning interest on your crypto today
you know I always think about like there
is catalyst to social unrest there are
the means that are pursued to kind of
show that social unrest and then there
is usually some sort of conclusion
whether that is a positive or negative
way that there's you know very few
instances in the world where social
unrest has persisted for you know
decades for example it feels like right
now we've got a good understanding of
the catalyst for what's going on in hong
kong and the media has done a pretty
good job of covering kind of the ways in
which citizens are showing their
unhappiness but what i don't hear a lot
about is kind of the conclusion and kind
of where realistically the social unrest
can can conclude any thoughts there in
terms of how you think this plays out
the reason why i didn't hear about it is
quite simple because nobody knows so i
choose to be optimistic i think that
this place has been through a lot over
the last few decades and it always comes
out on top and i think that this time
will be no different
Hong Kong will emerge out of this and it
will emerge stronger but you know how
long is it going to take and what will
happen between now and then the simple
answer is should nobody knows
yeah has there been any effect on your
business either positive or negative in
terms of the social unrest you see
capital flowing out of Hong Kong via
crypto do you see you know more people
signing up or maybe you see the exact
opposite effect that there's kind of
more concern either on a regulatory
basis or due to the social unrest what's
kind of the impact that you're seeing
Hong Kong is a very small market for us
we've got a global business or I can
tell you that you know I've seen more
impact from the restrictions that
Argentina put on crypto purchases I've
seen a flurry of activity there and
there's not much difference in Hong Kong
I think the the city has probably seen
like traditional capital outflows like
people selling on $10 and buying foreign
currencies and trying to hedge the risks
by moving capital out of the city into
places like Singapore for example right
that's a very common strategy that is
been happening for months right and
that's to a certain extent the cost of
letting this situation spiral out of
control but not much crypto impact today
makes makes sense and in terms of kind
of the future outlook for for crypto
comm maybe help us understand you know
where you you see yourself going in the
next kind of six to 12 months with other
things that are kind of on the horizon
that you're thinking about or is it more
of just execution on the things you
already have on your plate and that's
the focus you know so we just released
our roadmap for 2020 so it covers all
three key areas so payments financing
and trading so on the trading France we
starting with
exchange which is now in better and it's
going to be available to the public in
December then in the first half of the
year will very quickly follow up with
margin trading lending and derivatives
and this in terms of payments
we've got continued expansion globally
for a card program so we'll get a Latin
America plan for next year so as you
know Canada and a few other places to
have like very broad coverage of the
card product and a global distribution
network for that on the payments found
also our public chain which is now in
testement mode at the second vision test
and out two months ago next year is
where we go to the domain night stage so
that's going to be big for a big
milestone for the company and on the
finance fraud you know we are upgrading
our card product so that you will no
longer have to convert from crypt of the
Fiat if you want to have access to cash
will simply extend credit lines based on
the the fans you have encrypted are in
in the wallet in the critical mullet so
that's like in line with our ethos which
is if you disturb down to and we want to
you know people to be long crypto and
it's short yet so that's it sounds like
an easy concept but if you want to roll
it out globally again there are
implications on you know the regulatory
frauds licensing and whatnot so the
trading activities with fully station
offering the the main yet of our public
chain and an upgrade to the card
offering us like the three core product
initiatives for next year got it and
explain a little bit more about how that
line of credit works yes so it's very
simple so let's say you know you deposit
BTC or XRP or eath or whatever and let's
say you've got $10,000 of crypto in
totaling in in the custodial wallet
so if you want to spend on the card
we'll just front all your spending for
you and you can pay interest on whatever
you use from this credit line and we're
gonna go for super seamless user
experience and unfriendly interest rates
so actually keep the outside from
digital assets but you have and you only
pay the interest on that mmm on whatever
you spend so access to the cash without
the need to sell your crypto that's what
we're going for
got it and then I gotta ask you guys
don't crypto calm and has been a long
time sponsors of off-the-chain which
obviously I and listeners appreciate and
I always call out that you guys had the
best URL you know when we started and
when we did we did have tokens so I'm
2017 first half on people very strongly
associated us with the card because such
a cool product easy to understand about
now but over time it became clear that
what we were building is the entire
ecosystem that is focused on trying
crypto adoption so we looked at the
rebuilding options and I are the easiest
thing to do is just type in crypto to
come into the browser and see what's
there I don't
there was a lovely message from
Professor a lot blaze over there that's
talking about you know the fact that
crypto stands for cryptography and not
crypto currency and what he doesn't
advise anybody to use this as a vehicle
if you guys my own speculation so I sent
him an email
physically under so it started and as an
academic as you can imagine he's a he's
quite a character and a very outspoken
one so it took us a while to reach an
agreement but the gist of it is very
simple you know we always try to figure
out what are the potential reasons for
someone to say no and we just address
them one by one and in my
perience when people see that you
actually put some thought into it when
you approach them and try to understand
their concerns they will be willing to
engage and you know he held the domain
for more than 25 years right and and
there were I know hundreds of people
trying to buy it off him with you know
and being so persistent that he nights
after the fact I actually read some
articles about it on the verge the
people are actually stalking him a today
at the University and you know calling
his landline all this stuff crazy
stories so he was quite adamant but we
managed to to find a common common
ground is there anything that you can
share in terms of what his uh his
hesitancy was yeah yeah so again I think
he's he's he's just he's a very
well-known expert in cryptography right
so I think you know in order to make
sure that this lands in in responsible
hands and that he is free to express his
opinions and typically you know there's
like if you look at this type of
transactions there's you know so much
legally is around it and so many
restrictions on both sides if you want
to overcome this type of situations you
just need to you know understand each
other and there needs to be a
relationship of trust and I think
establishing that was critical for sure
and then um I'm assuming you won't
answer but uh you interested in sharing
how much you had to pay for it yeah I
think it just doesn't matter you know
people always sounds good but
realistically it it has it doesn't
matter because if we achieve you know
one-third of what we want to achieve
next 10 years this the euro is going to
be priceless so it just doesn't matter
cos we are legally not allowed to say
that's a good reason no so so before we
wrap up here one of the things that I
want to spend few minutes talking about
is time this vision that you have right
of every person in the world having a
digital wallet right and I think that
that it's one of the key pieces as to
you know why you and I kind of saw eye
to eye early on was that vision is
really important talk a little bit about
you know kind of how that happens and
then what the impact on the world is if
we can get to that point yeah so we
believe that it's your basic human right
to control our money your data and your
identity and Bitcoin has demonstrated in
a very powerful way is actually feasible
it is possible it's it's not done right
even you know you've got US congressman
saying that crypto is an unstoppable
force and every government that try to
stop it failed right so this can be done
it's very powerful now the question is
can we take this inside that you know
you can you can have this decentralized
technology that eliminates the need for
for an intermediary can we apply it to
other areas of life mmm I believe really
that the anti-facebook
for the lack of a better world is going
to come out of the block chain space and
and the society just needs it like I
don't know about you but yeah yeah I've
got a my son is about to turn 3 if I
extrapolate what is going on with big
tech and government overreach you know
like 15 to 20 years
III feel layer layer on top of this you
know that fast balance in AI and we're
ending up in a surveillance society is
very unhealthy
so blockchain has the potential to help
us build a healthier fabric for the
society and I'm not saying that people
who come is gonna go get it all done by
no no by any stretch of imagination no
but we think we have a role to play to
just making the size of this industry
bigger so the next time when there is a
guy who is some break for idea you know
I don't know an engineer I think someone
in Moscow or in Dubai or whatever right
that he will get funded that the
technology will be adopted and it will
be scaled and collectively as an
industry we just changed the world for
force curve and one thing you just said
they're super interesting to me right
you put ownership of money ownership of
data but also you put identity and one
piece I continue to think through is
that the digital wallet can be the
source of identity in the future in this
digital world you agree with that or
having any kind of nuanced views as to
how that happens yeah actually when I
think about identity I know you think
about it as you know the traditional
sense of the world of the world like you
know your passport or your your ID or
your driver license I couldn't care less
about that right but these days
everything you do online is
fingerprinted and the large terms like
Facebook or Google they know more about
you than any government you know they
know more about you than your mother
they know more about you than you know
about yourself and if you add to it the
ability to you know like blanket the
blanket coverage of entire cities with
HD cameras you know microphones and AI
on top of it
that's I think it's a very big problem
and I don't think it's very healthy so
how do we you know bring the puffins
back to the force in Star Wars parlance
how do we make it a little bit healthier
for the next generation I think that's
that's one of the fundamental questions
of our time got it in is your thought
process here you know over time there is
a evolution from those kind of
government-issued identifications or is
this a you know kind of abrupt decision
by somebody who says hey you know what
I'm going to kind of move over into the
alternative digital world and I'm going
to exclusively operate there like like
how does that transition happen I think
it's gonna be in small steps and I will
see first of all in governments you know
migrating to the blockchain tag just
because it's easier to manage this type
of stuff right and and there are there
are some simple benefits to it right but
again you know I don't think we can go
away from this country by country issued
IDs and whatnot okay very quickly it
will be a gradual evolution and you know
I personally don't subscribe to this you
know this nationalistic view of the
world there is a lot of people in this
space specifically who view themselves
as citizens of the world of the more
than one citizen of any given country
and I think if you if you look at like a
a couple decades down the road the world
is going to continue to get smaller and
smaller and the differences between us
are going to be reducing as well so who
knows now you can see like for example
in Europe right I mean I can take my
polish ID and I'm just going over a
freely within Europe I mean it's there
it's not impossible to see a future
where this can be extended so to cover
the health the health the whole fight
for sure before I get into the
rapid-fire questions what have you
learned over the last couple of years
building in the space what what's your
one main takeaway that you could share
with entrepreneurs now this time around
because again it's it's my first company
from day one we've invested very heavily
I thought so much about culture and how
not to screw it up and now three years
down the road this is starting to pay
huge dividends I'll give you a few stats
like almost 60 70 percent almost 70
percent of our team has been recruited
through personal referrals so you build
the team slower and if you do it like
this but it's just such a solid
foundation to build because people
really they worked with each other
before they know each other there's
really a relationship of trust so this
is much it's much stronger and a better
teamwork if you should believe a company
like this so when I was in my 20s I mean
I I read about how important culture is
for a company but now I've seen it
firsthand that it just makes such a huge
difference and as it is today culturally
great culture is our comparative
advantage people come to work for people
to come purely based on this and of
course I've got Coke products this is a
cool space and whatnot right but the
strong culture is so important for sure
for rapid-fire questions what do you
think the most important company in
crypto other than crypto comm is I don't
think it's the company it's just Bitcoin
itself it's a great answer that's
usually my answer what a one regulation
would you change or improve if you could
I would kill the bit license so we can
finally ship to our customers asking for
crystals comes frogs in New York I
normally would ask what your most
concert
thought is but I gotta ask you about the
controversial ad she put up all over San
Francisco many of these old things like
the 22 trillion dollar money printing
machine isn't gonna stop anytime soon
will plan being etc tell us a little bit
about that ad camp yeah I think you know
you we believe in what we do and we want
to connect with people like us
all right so by the way that the
Billboard about the 22 trillion printer
you know which will never stop it's kind
of out of date by now after three months
it's already 23 trillion nothing kind of
proves the point yeah but this is about
the crypto ethos and why are we doing
this all right at a very fundamental
level I don't know if you've seen this
like this is this decade ago there was
this powerful TED talk you know it's not
what you do is why you do it what's the
most important book you've ever read the
hard thing about hard things by Ben
Horowitz it's just so authentic this is
the life of a company builder and it's a
true page-turner and actually the very
frequently and give it away and to
people I come across such a great book
or sure aliens believer or non-believer
I'm a non-believer
non-blue oh no statistically you know
maybe there is something out there about
statistically we also will never find
out why do you think why do you not
believe if statistically it's likely
that there is something out there look I
mean the trillions of universes big
right but you know I just don't
subscribe to this you know area 51 that
wasn't I did you know somebody visit us
here and get some impact on how we
evolve I think there's the random part
of it you know evolution that's I think
this is more realistic view of things
of course at the same time one of my
favorite movies of all time is
prometheus because I absolutely love the
idea of space exploration and I'm a huge
fan of elan right and the idea that you
know that there is something there I
mean it's it's cool I like to so the
intellectual aspect of it is very
pleasant fine
but you know it's it's not something
that I wouldn't believe in likewise you
know I'm not religious I don't believe
in God either it's fair
what uh what question you have for me to
to wrap this thing up why have you kept
all the energy it's uh it's very similar
to you the answer he had earlier about
things that things that I get excited
about I don't hide that right it's kind
of this this level of authenticity of
what you see is what you get and so what
I'm excited you're gonna know it when
I'm mad you're gonna know it
and I always live my life with kind of a
couple of core beliefs and two of those
are one that enthusiasm is contagious
and so the more excited you are the more
kind of positive you are the more that
those who are around you kind of follow
suit and so you can change you know
people's attitudes and outlook just pure
enthusiasm it's likely even if it's fake
but but but especially when it's real
but on the other tenant I think is that
the you know the the hardships in life
or the battles and life if you will half
of it is literally just showing up every
day ready to tackle the day and so I
think a lot of people they try to
outsmart each other they try to do all
this stuff but I've just had a belief
that if you outlast everyone else you
win and so if you think about from an
energy standpoint it's just showing up
and realizing look I don't have to be
the
smartest person I don't want to be the
fastest person I don't have to be the
first person in everything but if I just
have consistency and energy that's you
know gonna put me way ahead of most
other people and you know that formula
sounds pretty simple
probably even sounds cheesy to some
people but at the end of the day it's a
formula that works and it's easy to
identify but it's really really hard to
execute because a lot of people you know
I always joke and say it's that random
Tuesday where they're writing something
or they're creating a podcast episode or
a video and for the last three weeks
they haven't gotten as much engagement
or distribution as they want that their
ideas aren't kind of resonating with
people in the way that they want and
they just say you know what I'm wasting
my time right and they walk away versus
if you think about you know take the
podcast for example I did 150 episodes
in the first year right and in the
beginning there was really not that many
downloads but over time you build an
audience and and it just takes time and
effort and showing up and so if you look
at you know the largest podcast in the
world today they didn't get started
yesterday right many of them are you
know four or five some even ten years
old and so it just takes a lot of
consistency and so if you know that
that's what it takes then you just gotta
show up every day with energy right and
so however you do that for yourself
whether it's you drink a bunch of coffee
you get a lot of sleep or you're just
excited about what you're doing you know
just show up and have the energy and the
rest kind of takes care of itself I
think ya know I think you're you know I
don't agree with the contagious nature
of your energy I think you're a great
asset to the entire industry because you
know we need people like with that level
of energy I also agree that you know
never ever giving up and just being
tenacious and the great this is this is
Halloween and it's actually much more
rare than what I would think for sure
well it's um I too
you know persistence is a superpower and
it's just this belief that you know
you're chipping away at something right
and there's this great image that I've
seen and I've talked about on my podcast
before but but it's just he's like
seared in my brain and it is two guys
each of them is in a separate tunnel one
of the guys is at kind of the beginning
of his journey he's got a pickaxe and
he's picking away at a you know a rock
based kind of wall and at the end of the
image is I think it's gold or diamond or
something and so he's got a long way to
go and he's really really you know it
looks like he's sweating profusely and
he's picking away trying to get through
that wall to get there but it was a long
way away and the other guy in the image
has already picked through the entire
wall and he's got you know just inches
to go to get to the diamond but he's got
his pickaxe dragging on the floor he's
walking away and it's just this image of
you know you never know how close you
are to the breakthrough and to me it is
less about hey where's the finish line
and it's much more about if you focus on
the process the results kind of take
care of themselves right and so part of
that process is you guys show up every
day gotta be enthusiastic you know
frankly you gotta try not to just be
stupid it is another one of my favorite
kind of views of the world is if you
just avoid making dumb decisions the
smart decisions are the only decisions
left and so that game of kind of
probability is super helpful but I think
all of these things are just more around
you know how do people think how do they
approach what they're doing and again
that focus on process will will Altima
take care of the results absolutely no
question about it
as somebody who hosts up three feet from
gold no question for sure well listen
Chris I really appreciate you taking the
time to do this like I said you've been
in
credible supporter of off the chain and
then obviously you know really driving a
lot of product innovation to get in kind
of adoption of Bitcoin and crypto
currencies and so I'm excited to kind of
see as you guys continue progressing and
and I really appreciate taking the time
to do this where can people go find more
about the company and the various
products there's an easy-to-remember URL
crypto of palm or twitter at crypto calm
there's a lot of news coming out every
single week so it's it's a good place to
stay in touch and thanks for having me
on the show today and I hope the next
time we can do it in your studio in New
York City you got a man you when you
come to New York will definitely have to
get you on video you're you're prettier
than me so at least people can stare
that's just factually accurate but
that's that's face-to-face mixed
absolutely i man sounds good we'll talk
soon
hey everyone pop here if you like this
episode of off the chain and want to
help us take crypto to the top of the
Apple Spotify and other podcast charts
please do us a favor and rate review and
subscribe to review simply go to the
off-the-chain homepage scroll down until
you see the five blank stars taking 15
seconds to fill those stars in and leave
a quick review goes a long way in
helping us take the entire crypto
ecosystem to the top of the charts I
appreciate you listening and see you
next time on off the chain